so again with the audio version of this
book you've done podcasts in between
each chapter where you're recapping
what's just happened and this time you
brought guests one of which was your
mother right and you spend a 35 minute
conversation sitting down with her and
talking about the experiences that she
had with your father and reflecting on
that right a lot of stuff you'd elected
to leave out of the first book so that
means there's been a journey that you've
gone through
to get to the stage where both you and
her and collaboratively you felt okay
sharing that publicly right like what's
that process like because your mum
didn't ask for this I mean you kind of
also did you put a book out there
because you thought it was useful and
now millions and millions of people know
about you but right you know the uh
gravity field of your notoriety is
starting to bring other people in as
well so what was the Journey of getting
to that stage like well it wasn't so
much me I had already laid out you know
a lot of [__] about me that was you know
pretty embarrassing and can't hurt me so
for her that actually helped her out
she said wow if you have the courage to
go out there and tell people all your
[__] you know and so that process was it
took about four years
of me working with my mom because you
know she was very damaged by what she
went through and so was I but I knew no
one was coming to save me so I had to go
ahead and fix my [__] and she kind of
lived in a different place
but whenever it can't hurt me it started
waking her up
that hey man why do you care
why do you care so much what people
think about you what you went through
why why are you putting so much
so much on other people
and what they may say about you like
there's some stuff I talk about you know
that is pretty embarrassing for some
people
but she got to a point of life where she
was able to you know stop caring because
we all have our [__]
no one like people it's so funny to me
there'll be people who are out here
commentating about people who are
[__] up out here famous people are
[__] up
and I don't know how they're able to do
that
when
I guarantee while your skeletons are not
being out there
if I were to open up your [__] door
[__] how how are you doing that
so I know that about everybody
like people love to talk [__] about
somebody and keep themselves out of it
and so we went through that journey
together and so it allowed her to come
out and say yeah [__] it you know I'm
I'm a big person who
I want to give people the confidence to
walk in the room of a million people
and none of them like you and you just
like say [__] you I'm good and walk out
with you by yourself
you helped your mom do that as well and
now she can look at everybody and say
yeah
I [__] married a [__] that
choked the woman to death I was in a bad
place
I'm good with that
one of the days that you focus on a good
bet in that conversation is the day that
she decided to leave your father right
and take you and your brother with her
was there anything that you learned
about upon reflection
where both of your experiences uh opened
up a new realization to you
that that was a hard time for her and
and for me also I was ready to leave a
long time ago I was just waiting for her
to get the courage to finally leave him
and um
I don't think anything from that really
I think that's where the damage really
began
I think for her when she left it almost
her fight
went away
and it's kind of like when you run 100
miles
when you sit down your body can then say
that's exactly what I was thinking I'm
done it's exactly what I was thinking
the second she left
that the Mind said oh my God like we can
we can be human it's like PTSD yes we
can be human and we're not fighting
anymore and it just swarmed the demons
that all that fight and all that [__]
was keeping away it just came and it
swallowed it swallowed her whole it also
swallowed me whole but once again like
we were talking about I got a chance to
watch her
and she set out the alternate blueprint
on how not to be
so I had a hard time learning growing up
but I was very smart when it came to
human beings
a genius
because I lived in such hell I was
always studying people who can I trust
who can I not trust energy I got really
good with energy can I this person's
energy good is it bad so I became a
genius on human beings
so I studied people all the time
I studied all the time
she also talks about
considering taking your own life oh yeah
were you aware of that before you
started working toward this book yeah so
yeah she she talked about that a few
times with me behind closed doors
and um
I'm surprised she did it
you know there's a lot of stories that
are still Untold
that she probably will never talk about
and I'll never talk about him until she
says it's fine but um yeah it was it was
a bad it was it was a bad way so I I
gave her credit for having the strength
to say okay
I need to continue on and figure out you
know what's next for me but she says the
only reason that she didn't go through
with it is because of you and your
brother because she knew that she would
be leaving you in the hands of this
Tyrant that was going to mistreat you
even more badly now that she wasn't
around to protect you yeah which is a
it's beautiful but it's also kind of a
lot of pressure it feels like a lot of
pressure for a child to be the reason
for his mother to to still be there and
it's also a
damning conclusion about the state of
her life right that the only thing
stopping you from taking your own life
is these two boys but it's also
beautiful in a way
because a lot of people only have one
thing
you don't need a lot of things
sometimes only thing that kept me with
that one step forward was one thing
and so that one thing can get you to two
things to three things the four things
so that was the beautiful thing about
that is that now she's 75 and she's
retired because of that one thing
how
I mean you're having this conversation
with your mum during the production of
the audiobook
you're having a conversation which is
difficult to have in private right with
two microphones in front of you knowing
full well that this is going out to
millions of people it's going to be
scrutinized it's going to be listened to
it's going to be reflected on how
difficult is it to watch your mother
opening up about an experience which to
you was traumatic and then reopening
those wounds in front of you and talking
about that for millions of people to
hear oh it's hard
it's hard but
it's necessary
why
to be able to own your trauma
to be able to own everything about you
and look it in the eye
like there's a part in eight mile
with Eminem the very end
when this white boy you know [__]
trying to make it in the rap world and
getting beat down and [__]
comes from some trailer park [__] and
he's like how the [__]
am I gonna win this rap battle because
my best friend got shot in the foot and
this dude slept with my girl and all
this [__] so what he does to take all
the power from the [__] girl
rap battle his ass he's like
I'm gonna tell you every [__]
thing about me
I'm just gonna [__] tell you
and that's how I feel about life
and that's how my mom now feels about
life
I'm just gonna [__] tell you
everything a [__] about me I'm not
gonna hide I'm not gonna do none of this
[__] and it's a refreshing feeling
when you can get in front of millions of
people get an audiobook and you can go
through your [__] and lay it out and you
walk away there's no more secrets
there's no more secrets like people say
oh hey Lance Armstrong you do steroids
no no no no yes
well I have nothing I have nothing wrong
with Lance Armstrong anybody else
telling [__] man
and guess what happens to the
conversation
it's over
it [__] ends there's a really telling
Moment In the book I think it's my
favorite part and it's not even in this
one it's in the audiobook and it's when
it's getting quite difficult with your
mum and you offer her a root out you ask
if she wants to take a break yup she
says no yeah I'm gonna keep going
so it seems like she's got a bit of that
dog in her as well oh yeah she had to
yeah she had to one thing that when you
grow up the way we kind of grew up
together so I look at it when you grow
up when she had she had 28 and my
brother at 24. so
um about that you know we grew up
together and you got to have a dog in
you
you have to have a dog in you man and so
you have to have it like like my
grandfather caught it a stiff upper lip
you better stiff up a lip so you know
yeah she has some dog in her she has
some dog in there she has to there's no
other way to make it out here
I mean you can't just always be
you know head down in the sand
you gotta learn to pick yourself up on
your own a lot of times these fights and
these battles you gotta be your own
[__] coach you gotta be your own
motivator and she had to do that several
times in her life thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that clip
with Goggins then press here for the
full episode in all of its glory and
don't forget to subscribe